all eyes on a key swing state today
president trump and joe biden are
holding
dueling events in minnesota after
trading blows on the campaign trail last
night
the president is hoping to turn the
state red for the first time in decades
and joe biden is trying to stop him
here's the former vice president just a
few minutes ago
in the midst of this unprecedented
national crisis
trump has given up on even pretending to
do his job
that if the president had just started
one week earlier
in march than he did we'd have 36
000 more people sitting at the dinner
table tonight
how many people across the iron range
how many empty chairs around those
dinner tables
because of his negligence and
selfishness
and president trump is set to respond
with a great american comeback rally
tonight
it comes as the candidates step up the
intensity of their attacks in key
battleground states take a look at this
if biden wins very simple
china wins if biden wins the mob wins if
biden wins the rioters
anarchists arsonists and flag burn as
they win
if the president had done his job had
done his job from the beginning
all the people would still be alive this
president should step down
joe biden devoted his entire career to
offshoring wisconsin
jobs outsourcing your factories
throwing open your borders i really do
view this campaign
as a campaign between scranton and and
park avenue
the way we were raised up here in this
area awful lot of hard work and people
bust the neck all they ask for is a shot
just a shot all that trump can see from
park avenue
is wall street
hey jesse maybe start with you i think
it's fifth avenue not park avenue just
you know for fact checking here
yeah i think you just were the only
person to fact check joe biden
dana i mean he got away with a whole lot
of doozies last night
i don't know i think minnesota is in
play and
biden's getting spread very thin he
hasn't been to minnesota in a thousand
days
and every day he has to go to a state
like minnesota which democratic nominees
never go to
is a day he's not going to be in a state
like florida
it looks like trump is doing five
rallies and five battlegrounds in five
days
and not only that the whole family's
involved trump jr is doing five
battlegrounds in five
ivanka is doing four battlegrounds in
five eric's doing four
and lara is doing a bus tour in florida
so they're really spreading joe biden
pretty thin right now
he's come out of the basement and he's
on defense and it's clear he wants to
talk about the coronavirus
and right now minnesota i think they're
averaging about nine deaths per day
and that's not as big of an issue as it
was this summer the president has
pivoted very aggressively to the economy
and that's great because the economy is
right now in a super v
and they're predicting unemployment at
five percent
next summer so that's the fastest
economic recovery
in u.s history i know juan wants to talk
about
the census report that just came out
juan
you can't argue with these statistics so
just sit there and listen
in 2019 the average american household
made an extra four thousand and four
hundred dollars
it is an all-time high now median income
at sixty eight thousand dollars
in just three years the average american
family has made nearly
nine thousand more dollars under donald
trump under barack obama in eight years
they only got a one thousand dollar
raise income inequality is now
squeezing compared to obama and biden
where it expanded
and the poverty rate has hit an all-time
low four million people
have been lifted out of poverty under
donald trump
a number like that we haven't seen in
over 50 years
that's why the president's going to
hammer the economic message and i think
that's why he'll win
so juan i'll give you a chance to
respond to that i did want to ask you
one question though about minnesota and
republicans
is it sort of fool's gold the way that
texas is for
democrats
minnesota dana yes
because i think i just saw that biden's
up
10 in minnesota so i don't think that's
what i mean
meaning that let me let me clarify no i
should clarify so
democrats keep saying they're going to
win statewide races in texas and they
never do
republicans are trying to win statewide
in minnesota and it has been elusive to
them
president trump's come closer than most
but this time around do you think the
republicans
are going to fall short again in
minnesota
well i mean you know obviously there's
an opportunity there
given the trouble that happened in
minneapolis with george floyd
and we've gone over some of the issues
like you know the city council
going back and forth on defund or reform
the police however you want to
you know put that together so i think
the president must
think that you know that message about
law and order and the like
has some resonance there but i i don't
know that it's working given
what i've just said about the polls but
i wanted to respond to jesse as well
and say jesse i think there are a lot of
americans who are going through real
economic pain
right now and a lot of that pain that
economic pain in terms of
unemployment specifically is tied
directly to the corona virus and we know
from the president's own words
that he wasn't straight with us well
when it's time to be shut down handled
it's not tied to the virus it's time to
shutting it down
and then reopening up and then building
it back the way it was no but i'm saying
gangbusters before
well i'm thinking that you know when i
look at other countries
uh you know our peers in the world
they've handled it better and their
economies they're coming back fast
that's actually false
your economy won't come economic
contraction in the united states
less than every single developed nation
okay
look i can see that our death rate our
infection rate much higher than other
developed countries jesse and what i'm
saying to you is
until we americans get together and
crush this coronavirus we can't expect
that our economy
is going to have a resurgence and that
means we can't be involved in
politicizing mass
politicizing when a vaccine is coming we
can't be putting pressure on our cdc
officials and
telling them oh yeah read you know
you're wrong about when the vaccine's
coming all right
that's got to stop and i think americans
see that
i agree let's not politicize it the
politics is here
um greg i want you to listen to joe
biden talking about
the mask mandate he's still talking
about it i would like to see
the governor's enforced mask wearing
period
i can do that on federal property as
president i will do that
and we could have a fine for them not
doing it look this is about saving
people's lives
what do you make of him not landing on
one consistent message
that's joe you know he'll say whatever
somebody wants him to say and if he
and if he realizes it wasn't the right
thing he'll just change it
um but somebody did fact check him uh
uh this is john carney john carney
i think it was over at breitbart i was
getting confused with his brother tim
um that quote that joe thinks is so
clever uh it's a it's a
election is it's scranton versus park
avenue
and he's right except that park avenue
supports biden
by a factor of an eight to one margin
yeah right and trump gets more money
from scranton than park avenue so
that's a good fact check i have to uh uh
credit john carney
i um you know that's this thing that he
keeps saying if we just started a week
earlier you would have saved 30 000
lives
why does he just say a week why doesn't
he say two weeks
why does it say three weeks do those
lives not matter
or is that are we starting to get into
the even deeper to the impeachment
uh territory where we knew that we had
completely missed this thing
because the democrats are obsessed with
impeachment but you know it's funny
uh he says that trump is responsible
for all the deaths and he said the data
backs him up and of course that's not
true
but joe's got to be super careful
because he's going to run
out of room for for future demonization
if he keeps making it bigger and bigger
and bigger
maybe donald trump next week will be
responsible for not all past
death but all future death maybe he can
link him to killing i don't know jesus
or jfk or mlk
i mean the dems i keep thinking they've
hit a limit on
how evil they can portray trump
i think they stopped comparing trump to
hitler not because it was
unfair to trump because they thought it
was unfair to hitler
because they actually think that he is
worse than hitler
this is it's getting to a point where it
is what's always been
hilarious watching that watching them
create these evil
uh fantasies but i just wonder where
they're gonna go next
where dana where yeah tell me once
you've already gone there there's
nowhere to go emily let's give you the
last word
greg there is definitely no limit i'd
like to address the clips that we played
in the beginning of this segment
we know that biden plays the union angle
well right that's why throughout the
course of his career
he's set up those events so frequently
and really relied on them as his comfort
zone
but while he's palling around with the
union bosses i think he should be more
concerned
with the union workers as dana mentioned
we know that trump carried more union
workers in minnesota in 2016
than any republican since reagan but
he's delivered
on the promises that he made to them
this administration
expedited mining contracts which is
critical in minnesota he renegotiated
nafta
and many union members are upset and
concerned about the direction that the
democratic party is going with gun
control and obviously energy
quick final point remember in july when
biden held that virtual event with
minnesota union
bosses a few days after he released his
environmental plan the union bosses
cheered the plan
but a few days later the workers were
pulled and they said that what was most
important to them
was steady good paying jobs and what
brings steady good-paying jobs to them
they associate it with traditional
energy and infrastructure jobs the
renewable energy
is not the source of it so that's where
biden should be concerned